maintenant que c'est tombé le poker vous
avez moins besoin d'argent quand même ah
oui beaucoup moins beaucoup moins fait
beaucoup des choses très classe ça me
coûtait très chaud je perdais mon argent
montant mes nerfs mais nuit et mes amis
qui dirait des clients c'est vrai que
vous étiez fait interdire en france et
vous alliez jouer à l'étranger ces
messieurs 50 m
et alors ça vous coûte encore plus cher
parce qu'il ya le voyage on va voir un
truc justement sur better anonyme oui
allez voir aujourd'hui beaucoup de
français résiste mal aux facilités de
crédit offertes par les banques et les
organismes de prêt accro à la carte
bleue ils sont saisis d'une forte fièvre
acheteuse est sombre inexorablement dans
le surendettement pour les aider une
association les débiteurs anonyme vient
de se créer à paris à l'église
américaine sur le modèle des alcooliques
anonymes
en général ce type d'association l'idée
jeunes qui ont tous eux mêmes problèmes
entre eux se réunissent pour réapprendre
à nouveau comportement avec l'argent
alors cet effet j'en ai je dit qu'ils
sont sans doute tenir à jour
argy de ses dépenses et
bon pas dans le but de budgétiser mais
vraiment dans le but d'apprendre à faire
face toutes ces réalités de l'argent on
peut organiser des réunions de ce qu'on
appelle des réunions de décompression
est vraiment de mettre tout simple à
doser en parler on sachant que les
personnes à qui on m'en parle ont connu
le même problème que donc en parler en
déculpabilisant à maximum quand on
rencontre les débiteurs d'anonymes on
peut se demander s'ils font pas partie
d'une secte un petit peu parce qu'il ya
quand même un embrigadement il ya un
jargon il ya des mots qui reviennent
souvent un peu du lavage de cerveau quoi
alors effectivement ils ont douze
commandements dont le premier est
l'abstinence
quoique on leur dit qu'on leur dise pas
de jeter leur carte de crédit leur
chéquier terrain lors des fêtes des
dettes mais si vous pouvez les
remboursements c'est pas du tout une
secte
c'est effectivement faire appel à une
puissance supérieure que chacun peut
avoir au fond de soi est vraiment une
puissance supérieure tels que chacun
conçoit qui peut être finalement le bon
sens qui peut être la partie saine que
bon que tout individu a en lui et
apprendre vraiment servir cette partie
scène justement pour faire face
ces problèmes d'allaitement parce que
cependant une autre immense un problème
je crois d'ordre mental secte pas c'est
qd je sais pas mais parle beaucoup de
dieu alors c'est un petit peu inquiétant
si c'était politisé je crois que ce
serait carrément dangereux alors dit on
revient tout le temps et a par exemple
la fin de chaque séance
les videurs anonymes se réunissent comme
ça en rond d'estienne la main et récite
une prière que j'ai sous les yeux shmuli
mon dieu donnez-moi la sérénité
d'accepter les choses que je ne peux
changer le courage de changer les choses
que je peux et la sagesse donc renaître
la différence amen
des alcooliques anonymes philippe
bouvard à l'oreille et doucement ouais
rambaud à toi tu joues s de l'info est
de l'intox on t'écoute
il me fait peur et son couteau lui pas
vous du rire l intox
oui james oshie a battu hawkswood donc
je peux le dire maintenant nous avons
trois intox autour de nous il y avait un
qui doit se lécher les babines
c'est notre expert philippe guérin je me
lâche pas du tout les babines j'ai
carrément la trouille sylvester
excuse-moi james excusez moi philippe
excusez moi c'est de l'info applaudi et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un peu
de bleu